hey guys it's justine and guess what
we've got today
brand new apple watches we have the
apple watch series 6 and the apple watch
se to check out
plus some new bands so the series 6 that
we have today
is the blue aluminum case with the deep
navy sport band and the sc
is the space gray aluminum case with the
charcoal spools
boot the charcoal sport loop
let's unbox tyler do you so i don't have
a child
and would you mind acting as though you
were a child today
for the sake of this video you're gonna
have to do your math
all right let's unbox starting with the
series of six
[Music]
the apple watch unboxing process is
beautiful
like just look at this it's so graceful
maybe that's me
[Music]
smells so good and fresh and new and
fast
smells like we're gonna get a faster
charge time out of this watch
i hope this is a little hint of what's
to come
in the iphone because this color is
amazing you've all seen
the sport bands that this comes with but
let's open it anyway give you another
look
oh wow oh this is nice it matches it
perfectly
oh my goodness i'm gonna i'm gonna just
put it on because i
i can't wait any longer
i will say the one thing that i am going
to miss the ceramic
apple watch cases these are so nice like
it's just
beautiful beautiful but
we all have to move on sometime does
have an integrated infrared sensor now
which will assist with
the blood oxygen readings i will be
doing a follow-up video so make sure you
guys are subscribed and hit the bell so
you'll be notified when that video comes
out
this is more of an unboxing and kind of
an overview of these watches and a first
little test
see how it works gotta pair this up look
it's asking if i'm setting this up for
myself
or for a family member i am left-handed
so i wear my apple watch
on my right wrist a lot of you guys
always are making fun of me because you
think that i'm wearing it backwards or
upside down but i do flip the
orientation so that the buttons are in
the front on my right wrist so here it's
asking me which wrist do i wear my apple
watch on
right next up se it's crazy you don't
even need an axe to open this
[Music]
oh this blue sport loop is very nice
these are review units the one that i
ordered is the graphite stainless steel
so that will be
arriving very shortly
[Music]
it's so cool
one thing i did notice is they didn't
really put any big identifying features
on this do you guys remember when they
had the red dot on i think it was the
series four maybe they now have just
sort of the little
red ring around there it's asking me if
i want to check my blood oxygen
yes your apple watch is almost ready
you'll get an alert when it's done
so now it's going through the final
stages of setup and it's showing me all
of the apple watch basics
but we know the basics but if you don't
this is really great because it will
give you a quick tutorial
this is the charcoal sport loop let's
open this take a little look
so if you are getting this blue series
six this is one that you should
definitely consider checking out
now time to check out some of these
watch bands they sent a few different
sizes to test out so the sizes that i
have here are
two and a three but when i did measure
my wrist with their little paper
measuring thing i did get a size five so
the number between the arrow is my band
size
looks like i'm a five so hopefully these
fit if not that's okay because i do have
my size five ordered and it will be here
hopefully within the next week or so
oh whoa this is so nice oh my goodness
there's no way this is gonna fit on my
wrist okay it might
but that's really small oh it's stretchy
holy moly maybe it will fit okay this
might actually fit
oh no this fits perfect oh shoot i did a
very poor job measuring oh no
it fits it's it's a perfect fit actually
i might be a two
oh no i'm gonna try the two and see what
that feels like
i can't believe how comfortable this is
first of all this is even more
comfortable than the sport loop it's
nice and stretchy
i think i'm a two i think i'm a two i
gotta tell jenna when i measured i got
ten
so i'm probably like a six or a seven we
still have that piece of paper
i did something wrong
okay i thought that it was supposed to
be between the arrows if i'm making it
pretty tight it's saying a four but
the end of this is hitting around two
so if you're like me and has very poor
judgment of measuring
make sure you do a better job of
measuring and make sure if you do print
this out there is a little credit card
thing that will show you if it's the
right scale or not but i will
tell you that this is by far my favorite
apple watch band
of all time hands down look at this
where are my hands
they're down it's it's it's perfect we
have one more that i want to show you
okay so since this
size two fit i'm gonna open up the size
two the
silicone fitted band this is the solo
loop oh
it's so stretchy ah okay this
reminds me of like a fruit by the foot
i'm gonna put this on
this dude oh my gosh i think it's almost
ready i'm not ready yet
hold on a second i'm gonna put you i'm
gonna put this one here
this is so exciting this is so exciting
i'm so excited i'm so excited if anybody
tries to rain on my parade of my
excitement i will mute you
maybe i'll block depending upon my mood
this is my parade
look how small that is it's like
wow all right let's put this on
it fits perfect it's also comfortable
it's so comfortable i don't know why
it's so comfortable there was never
really a time that i thought wow my
apple watch
is uncomfortable before i would normally
take it off sometimes for a nap
stress to you guys enough how awesome
this is i don't even know how to explain
it in the words
that are coming out of my mouth other
than there's a huge difference
it's like the material is super light
and because it's stretchy
it doesn't feel like it's constricting
my wrist but man this is going to be so
great for workouts
for actually tracking your sleeve
probably would use this one
more often for workouts or hikes or
things that i probably
would be sweating because i don't
usually like the feeling of the sweat in
these
silicone bands because it's really it's
not a good feeling and these ones are
easier to clean
i will sometimes throw these bands in
and laundry and then i have to go
have a scavenger hunt trying to find it
when i'm putting clothes away
set up noise notifications yes this is
actually my first time trying watch os 7
i didn't install the beta
just because i didn't install the beta
and i didn't
so that's really the only reason so here
we are this is my first watch os 7
experience all right we're going to set
up the se we're going to set this up for
tyler he's going to be acting as
my son today the setup is happening now
so here are the new apple watches the
series 6 and
the se we're first gonna start talking
about the apple watch series six
so it has a new updated gold a stainless
steel graphite which is the one that i
ordered and this is the aluminum blue
and the product red is also a new color
so you can also now measure your blood
oxygen level
right on your wrist and it only takes 15
seconds if you want to check it manually
but it will automatically be taking
readings throughout the day
in the background it also has a new
improved always-on display that is 2x
brighter and includes an always-on
altimeter the battery life is around 18
hours with an improved faster charge
time and this is gonna be great if you
plan on using this for sleep tracking at
night so you'll be able to charge it up
faster in the morning as soon as you
wake up and we'll be ready for the rest
of your day so they once showed a demo
of being able to unlock and start your
car with your phone or your apple watch
so this does have a u1 chip
installed in it so that feature will be
enabled if your car does support it the
back of the watch has also been
redesigned with a new sensor to
incorporate the new o2 readings it's
made up of four led clusters and
four photo diodes in the back sapphire
crystal window
green red and infrared leds shine light
onto the blood vessels
inside of your wrist to measure the
amount of light that's reflected back
this then uses algorithms to calculate
the color of your blood which will give
you your o2 reading
generally you want to be within the 96
to 99
range in watchos 7 the new sleep
tracking will help you establish a
regular bedtime routine which i think is
almost impossible for me because of my
editing shooting and gaming schedule
but i will definitely be giving that a
try as soon as i get longer than a day
to spend with it so look for the full
review
apple also announced fitness plus that
will launch later this year which is an
on-demand fitness program with treadmill
hit rowing
dance cycling yoga core strength and
mindful cool down exercises
this will all integrate right into your
apple watch giving you all of your
metrics right inside the fitness plus
app while you're working out alongside
of it this will be 9.99 a month and
you'll get three months free when you
buy
a new apple watch there's also new watch
bands there's a seamless solar loop band
without clasps or buckles and you can
actually print out a chart to measure
your wrist to make sure you get the
correct size now i love my current watch
face but they also released some new
ones as well and they even have some for
different categories of interest
like ones for photographers or
adventurers and even them emoji one
which i think is my favorite
family setup is an amazing new addition
for people who want to get an apple
watch for their children before you
would need an iphone to set up an apple
watch so with this feature
you'll be able to set them up an apple
watch without having a phone they'll
still be able to make calls
text message use walkie-talkie play
music find apps
and even close their activity rings each
account will have their own apple id and
phone number the series 6 is starting at
4.99 for gps and cellular and 3.99 for
gps
the sc is 329 for gps and cellular and
279 for just gps so the sc is basically
the 6 but without the ability to take an
ecg
blood oxygen it doesn't have an always
on display and it does only come in
aluminum
silver space grey and gold either way
there is now an apple watch for everyone
and i love the fact that they have
brought the cost down
so that everyone can be able to have
some of these incredible features while
still making it affordable
my watch is set up my son's watch is set
up
tyler picked a toy story watch face for
his watch face because he's
acting as a child and i've already
restricted his access all day
he's in school time mode
so here's our conversation so far i have
messaged tyler my son have you done your
homework and you said sorry i can't talk
right now so it's cool when i synced up
his account we basically made an apple
id
he now has an entire separate account
that he's able to receive messages
but for the most part he's a
full-fledged apple watch that he can use
and do things the one thing that's
really cool about the kids account is
instead of
activity tracker tracking calories it
tracks activity minutes because i feel
like most kids you don't want to get
them like super obsessed with calorie
counting
and instead get them just hyped up about
activities
and keeping track of things that way
hello my son
this is absolutely not your mother this
is okay this is weird
i cancel i cancel so the biggest new
thing in the apple watch theory 6 is
being able to
test your blood oxygen level so i have
my watch face all set up this is kind of
carrying over from my previous gen watch
face
i love to be able to have access to my
activity my messages my fitness to
quickly add a workout
and now the blood oxygen level i also
like to be able to take my heart rate at
any point of the day
which is why this is nice and centered
so i can just be able to see it at any
point
are you ready to take my blood i gotta
go like this this only takes 15
seconds to test and my last one was 98
and it was an hour ago
here we go
[Music]
oh my goodness
somebody has achieved a perfect 100
blood oxygen score oh wow i'm printing
this out i know you guys might think
that this is a little bit crazy
but i actually do test my blood oxygen
level at least once a day i do have this
little tracker
to try out because i did a video
previously talking about some health
tech that i have
and a lot of you said to try this so
this one
is saying it's 97 you're having a
discrepancy
all right i'm gonna take this one more
time and have both of these on so the
apple watch is still saying 100
and the ring is saying 99 and one of the
things that i
actually read online before this was
like months ago when i was doing blood
oxygen research about different devices
that normally there is a
two percent chance of error in a lot of
these devices so i think the real
key thing here is if it is extremely low
then maybe you should
seek some sort of medical advice i think
these are really just supposed to be
gauging some averages but as far as
accuracy
the ring is still saying 99 and my watch
is saying 100
so normally i do find myself ranging
between
98 and 99. the most important thing for
a lot of people is just to know what is
normal for you
and kind of go from there and if you are
actually physically not feeling well
don't rely on your apple watch don't
rely on some sort of
medical device do go to the doctors and
seek help that's just
that should be common sense but
something that needs to be said so we've
tested our o2 i'm gonna just take an ecg
just to really get an overall gauge of
my
well-being today so for the ecg
you just hold your finger right on the
crown for 30 seconds
and it should give you a pretty accurate
reading
this ecg does not show signs of atrial
fibrillation
i like that all of this does integrate
right into the health app so here's my
activity
i did a run this morning i forgot what i
was doing respiratory blood oxygen and
your vo2 max
for the past 30 days i've actually never
looked at this before a higher vo2 max
indicates a higher level of cardio
fitness and endurance this is actually
quite fascinating because
december 2019 it was lower
and then i started running a lot more
this year so that's really crazy because
you can actually see it
i can i'm seeing my fitness look at all
this freaking data
well i'm glad this now has added blood
oxygen because that is just another
added level of being able to quantify
your health
they've also added in some new watch
faces i have mine all custom set up here
now
i like them emoji apple watch face
that's cool
what if you can change the color oh yep
look at this
so if you guys watched the announcement
i did post a video that has everything
covered that they talked about so i'll
put a link in the description if you
want to go
into more detail about everything the
new ipads all the things that are
launched in the new apple watch but i
cannot wait for fitness plus
fitness plus is really cool if you guys
haven't seen this yet it's going to be
apple's on demand fitness classes and
it's amazing because it syncs
directly to your apple watch so you'll
be able to see all of your metrics on
screen and
if anybody has a peloton out there i'm a
huge fan of peloton what they do with
being able to quantify your metrics
and the integration with the apple watch
i do wish that they would integrate with
the treadmill
but i will keep my fingers crossed that
there's some sort of firmware update
because
i do feel like you could just connect it
to bluetooth and be able to do that but
the fact that apple is offering this
on-demand service
for 9.99 if you've never worked out
before this is going to be a really cool
way to start because you can work out on
your phone
on your apple tv on all of the devices
your ipad so if you do have an apple
watch you'll be able to sync it up and
be able to track
all of your progress it was kind of
crazy though because actually just
looking at my data
i was really able to see the progress
that i've made and i haven't actually
looked at that in a while but it's
really cool to see that all the work
that i put in
to trying to be healthier and work out
is actually
making a difference i mean i feel better
but like i the data
is here i saw it with my own eyes and
you guys saw it as well
we're gonna try to squeeze in a whole
review but we realized that this is
basically just one day with the apple
watch
and i wanna really do this justice and
kind of show you guys all of the
scenarios
so we're gonna be spending the next
couple of days testing this out i'm
going to
test out the sleep test out the fitness
test out the
always-on altimeter i'm gonna take my
sister hiking and we're gonna really put
this thing through the paces
one two three team i love this thing so
much already i love the apple watch
[Music]
you